this is grunted Sigler in Berlin at Iona
visited Berlin at the seminar room of
the villa which belongs to the discrete
geometry group Tama professor of
mathematics here and this is sort of my
home what's a perfect proof I I don't
know this that's the story that God has
this book with which has the perfect
proofs and we think of it as a fat book
but the proof says such they should be
short and elegant and in some way
surprising and I think this element of
surprise that there's some tools used or
some idea comes in that isn't just
straightforward that sort of what makes
it makes it interesting for us for an
example I'd always start at the
beginning
there's Euclid's elements from 300
before Christ which is the first real
math book and where he proves that this
infinitely many Prime's so if any finite
set of primes then there's always one
more set of prime and Euclid's element
is that if you have a finite set of
primes and he just talks about three of
them but any finite set you just take
the product plus one and then you figure
out that this product plus one can't be
divisible by any of the old primes
because they divide the product so they
can't divide the product plus one which
means if you take product plus one
that's a larger number and it has to
have a prime factor if it's not a prime
by itself and this prime factor has to
be new I mean why is this perfect
because it's so short as an argument and
so striking and in some sense it's the
model of a proof although there's been a
lot of debate about it people today
would usually phrase it by contradiction
so assume we have all the primes and
then you show that there's a
contradiction because there's new one
but you could himself wrote it up with
without a contradiction you just showed
if you have three Prime's there's a
fourth one so that's always something
new it's sweet and it's elegant and it's
short